yeah hello and welcome
to this video long time no see i was
extremely busy in recent weeks
to finish my newest course on chessable
and it's out now for almost a week and i
had to do
some tidying up so finally i can make a
video again with uh
like not being completely stressed out
and um
i want to make a quick tournament video
a re-arena tournament on
only chess but before i get there i just
want to
quickly make sure that you are on the
page for the black friday sales
if you want to get one of my courses it
could be the new one here the lifetime
repertoire
c419f3 this is still on for three days
and the discount is like close to 50
percent i think
so if you um are interested
in the course make sure to check it out
and
there's currently also the keep it
simple e4 and d4 they're both on sale so
if you want to get one of those make
sure to be quick
they are only on for two days and um the
other courses like
fight like magnus fight like karana the
nimzera goes in they will be on sale as
well over the next couple of days
so make sure to monitor chesable and uh
make sure to um yeah get take advantage
of the
of the discounts so um now
let's go and play a tournament i've made
this a fairly simple layout it's not
maybe the most efficient one
but i want to get make sure that
that i get everything on the page that
you see everything
the board will be a little bit smaller
but that's what it is
um i'm going to play the the five minute
hourly blitz and
treat this as a little bit of a an
exercise for
later tournaments to happen
and i'm berserking every game at least
that's my plan
i'm not sure about this tournament how
strong this is i don't play in them all
that often
yeah i hope to have more videos out over
the next days and
maybe this is not yet completely settled
there will be some news regarding more
content but yeah
it's not yet really ready to talk about
it so maybe i will do much more
stuff on my channel
twitch and i'm not quite sure but
we'll get there soon enough okay now
this is a fun way to play i guess going
for b5 i go with g4 g5
this is really dangerous for both sides
mostly for black but i'm firing away
here i have berserked and
uh it doesn't really make sense to
be too subtle about things let's go for
mate
yeah one thing that i also want to make
sure that you know
there is of course um the tournament
starting today
the i think it's called skilling open
yeah
i'm not really good with those names and
this is the super strong online
tournament uh featuring
um the world champion but also many
other top players
and actually i'll be doing commentary
for that
tournament for one of the rounds
and that will be on tuesday i will put
out a message um
or a video on my channel to make that um
clearer when when the day happens it
should be on tuesday
i'm going to be live together with simon
williams
on his channel i think it's going to be
on his ginger
gm channel and i think this will be this
will be much fun
so looking forward to do the
commentary together with simon
again i will post this um on that
tuesday
to make sure that nobody is is missing
that that's a really strange position
here
no clue what's going on he wants to go
knight c4 i don't know
what's going on here um
i do i mean this looks nice but i don't
quite know how i'm continuing here
1 33 i'm i have berserked so
i have to make sure not to
fall asleep this one attacking the a
pawn
my knight is a little bit
oh it's a little bit offside here
and i have to make sure that he's not
getting some decisive breakthrough here
on the um on the with c3
on the um center and queen side
now i'm getting to c3 it seems it's got
94.
no this one okay at least um nothing's
going to happen
here okay let's go a4 i still have an a
pawn
he wants to catch the the h pawn which
he
is successful in doing let's do this
and now what my king is not playing at
all which is a problem
i don't know maybe here and then e4
that's really fun here he's got the c3
stuff always
i mean i'm i'm just in time to to to to
catch him but
it's probably a draw huh can i do
something else
this is that possibility maybe i can
fight a little bit more with this move
but it could be risky
i've got 47 seconds that's not so much
interesting but i have this um
a7 i don't know a7 looks wrong
i hope i'm not risking too much here a7
rook a8 knight c8 is probably
picking this up i want to invade with
the king that's my idea
okay what is going on here i can go to
b6 huh
i cannot actually but i can go to b form
this is totally fine
the a pawn is extremely dangerous here
because the knight is so bad and
stopping it
so let's push forward and maybe now
knight knight b5 looks bad
let's get the pin going
this one
knight c895 maybe he can go c3 then huh
shoot
didn't do that okay let's catch the pawn
i can't simply take the friggin friggin
a7 pawn
i didn't see that coming
that's stupid okay this is the draw
but i have to be really fast
okay it's not trying for any weird time
place
now that was bad should have won that
game
probably i'm not totally sure
okay i get another dirty harry on the
board not sure dirty harry is probably
not on sale but it's not such a
um it's not a huge course
uh check it out it's a really fun course
that's a dirty hairy with h5 white does
not seem to be prepared
as they usually are
and it's a well-known mistake
[Music]
it's one of the tricks
and black is winning him
yeah i just have some extra material
a pawn is a pawn is a pawn now
they can still be annoying here with
knight b5 knight d5 stuff
how to play that this knight has no
squares
probably i cannot i mean i have h7 which
is which is good
i want to play e6 and a6 that would
patch
d5 and b5 nicely and here i have to go
to h7 but
that's not so much of a long-term
problem
i even see the chat here that makes no
sense yeah i mean i have to adjust that
if i have a bit of time but i wanted to
make this video
this afternoon also to make sure you
got some time to actually
take advantage of the sails if you want
to
okay and this this is a fairly easy
position they've got the pawn and
it's fairly straightforward
it doesn't really have any counterplay i
have to really play quicker
i have to get into streetcar so this is
so important here in those tournaments
king is doing a good job there
helping helping to push the center
forward
i'm going e5 next i guess
i don't see why not i could even prepare
that with rookie 8
but
white doesn't really have all that much
that he can do
so let's prepare it
sometimes i have to okay
let's stop g5 it's still
time i don't have to play e5
all of the time actually i can also do
do this in a different way
what about d4 here it takes it's not
completely clear
yeah and just let's just regroup this a
little bit
knight d7 e5 rook f4 it's also nice
i should also not forget about d4
and knight doesn't have many squares
all right knight e5 is also totally fine
very harmonious
attack the pawn on g4 and
knight e3 i just have d4
the bad thing is that this this all
takes time
and i wanted to try to win this
tournament but
first game was already a setback a long
game with the draw is really not good
okay now how do we win this
maybe get the e pawn in motion
e5 e4
knight was nice on e5 but i think i need
the pawn
to win the game
the good thing is that my pieces here
are completely
stopping any rook activity he's got no
counter play
that is nice
i was thinking c3 at least but doesn't
seem to be on his agenda
like now there's never c3 because of d3
so let's go here threaten knight f3
now knight g2 to f4 is really
i could have played e3 actually but
it doesn't doesn't really matter i think
it's already completely beyond repair
yeah i'm winning the bishop now got d3
next
yeah that's nice it's always good in
those tournaments if they resign
and not stall it makes no sense for them
to stall because they cannot score
points um but it's mostly a thing of
like yeah strolling
if you don't resign this
maybe i should play some gambit stuff
when i'm playing my normal repertoire in
those eye that was
different stupid i don't want to this is
about the only move where
c4 is not so great but he's already
playing in a strange way he could have
played d for them
not the end of the world but it's it's
definitely something that
that helps black
okay and let's damage the pawn let's
damage the pawn
structure and be annoying on that pawn
yeah that's actually a good move how did
he see that
okay i don't want to take it gives
enough gibs
gives him too much activity
i was a bit stupid
now he's doing a good job good job so
far after the initially
somewhat shaky opening moves
that's a strange one though what do
where do you go with this
aha okay
shouldn't get checkmated that's that's
really not
the way to do it
he's got this check but it's really just
a check
so let's push everything forward
yeah maybe i should play some wacky
gambit stuff and
try to win quickly i mean this is not
even
obviously great for me it's just like if
i if i'm winning it takes a long time
so
i always have to check those kind of
oh wow okay
so i cannot take c6 because of knight
takes
this one would no it doesn't even
threaten h3
how do i thread in h3 here rook f3
yeah threatening h3
uh for a queen
it looks a little bit weakening my back
rank
but rook d1 i have uh covered
i think i'm winning winning stuff okay i
take with the rook i mean he has this
check
but it is still still the right move
let's do it
probably queen will move to h form yeah
i can take it yeah
it doesn't really doesn't do much
i currently have a bit of a problem to
move the bishop but
bishop e3 maybe returning some stuff
yeah that looks like a right choice
okay
it would be nice if you would just
resign this
simply for the tournament's sake of
course it's got every right to continue
it
just helpful if they don't stall
okay
okay so what's the position here in the
tournament
20th yeah okay i got two wins at least
so the next one would be a five pointer
it's very close here so i might be
on the way to the first page if i get a
win but
it's really it's a short short
tournament i think
for five minutes and our tournament is
really a bit short
okay
well
early time for for i think
okay
this is maybe a little bit dicey but
need to be quick
let me just attack this pawn on d3 maybe
i can just
i can just win it and that's the case
is there a trickery i mean i just it was
a case
of take first and think later right
but it just works so okay now i
think
i would like to trade queens my king is
a little bit unsafe
you know with the bishop always having
this
diagonal it could be a bit of a problem
yeah it's not
the knight is not going anywhere i am
okay i can take her
just stop knight g5 e5 next and then
i can start to convert
he still has a bit of activity it's not
extremely simple
night here oh that's a bit of a problem
okay
it never did that it would have been a
bit annoying 93.
yeah that looks good i can just do this
centralize
yeah a pawn is too strong
i can also go here let's do this
knight d6 a4 it's just
very fast
oh okay
oh come on
yeah one of the pawns will do the job
okay now what's the situation um
now wow okay first place will be
difficult to get
uh nine points this guy has won all the
games
that's not bad yeah that that first game
man that it took a long
time and it was just a draw it draws
i mean the draw isn't terrible but you
have to do it quickly at least
but uh
the way to go is probably to to beat the
guy
to beat first place
maybe i can can do something quickly in
this game that looks
extremely dodgy black's play here
queen h6 is knight g form
let's not be too
too aggressive there
like unwarranted unwarranted wow
difficult aggression can easily backfire
oh that's going to be very dangerous now
bit surprised that he has taken
this one on knight 94 also looks good
knight f6 not sure g4
i mean that is super dangerous
so let's get this one
or i can just take taking is not bad
h5
knight c6 say he has to do this but okay
i'm really fast here
with the attack
and now how do we checkmate
him don't see it
it's not good
this one
you can take with the d knight
and then i don't see the maid it's kind
of embarrassing i don't see that i don't
see a mate
because there probably is one
ok
at least he's playing cochlear okay i'm
thinking
mate yeah
so third place yeah the five pointers i
mean this guy has to lose a game
either against me or against somebody
else
about 30 minutes
and this is the person i made a draw
against in the first round
and that is not a particularly good line
but um in blitz i'm doing quite okay
with it
often getting oh that's very boring
very very boring often getting positions
that you can play quite quickly which is
just useful
okay i could do this
maybe i can irritate him with bishop f5
i'm not sure if it's objectively good
but
yeah that's that's annoying
that's annoying knight b3 coming here we
go
so let's take this
still have to be a little bit cautious
because
the dark squares are a little bit weak
this is why i'm trying to
um trying to
give him some material just to make sure
he doesn't have that much
attacking potential
okay and not so fast don't want to
give up the pawn that easily it's not so
easy actually this one
for d4 maybe still covering this pawn
for the moment
rook d4 next i'm happy that he doesn't
have the dark squared bishop anymore
is taking a long time that looks good
yeah it's a good move probably
okay let's centralize queen f3 is that
the idea
no okay
oh that's helpful
[Music]
i mean the result was not endowed really
but at least this is fast
need more of that
no please not a benoni this kind of
banco bank oops is fine
okay probably just this one
getting a type of tarrasch
isolated pawn yeah this is fine for
black
i'm not better but it's it's completely
okay
why doesn't he just take hmm okay
all right rook c8 i'm this is this is
completely okay
but it's a bit it's a bit uninteresting
let's say
maybe i shouldn't have played d4
not that it wasn't a bad move but it
just completely
sucks the life out of the position
it is a move that solves all the
problems but also
does not pose any
that's sometimes uh an issue hey you
want you play the best move and it's not
helping you to win the game but it's
just a
like a dead equalizer
yeah it's got knight c5
i can do this this is not
probably a an issue it looks a little
bit strange
my setup like there could be some
tactical problem
i want to go b6 next
add a4 could go a4 maybe and then i
don't have any squares for the queen
that is a thing
that's not good at all
i don't see a playable move hmm that's
not good
b6 a4 queen e8 looks looks awful but
i don't know what else actually
didn't see a good move at all
now a4 is just
coming queen e8
rook takes c4 b takes c5 it's just much
better for white
okay he tries to do something even
cleverer let's say
more clever and maybe he's right
so i go here and then bishop takes a6
okay okay
[Music]
yeah that looks very very grim
i got no time and uh
he's finding all the good stuff
i have only very slim hope uh
with the back rank but it's not really
queen takes c4 is a cheapo
which he has stopped okay
between c7 and it's not really a threat
maybe i should resign that's the right
way to do it
just play for go for the next game
[Music]
you never like to do that of course
i don't i don't have any tricks is the
thing
he's got bishop on c4 otherwise
that was that was extremely extremely
bad
guys just winning all the games which is
possible the opposition is very soft
and i mean my opponent played played
well
last game but two thousand two hundreds
that's usually not so much of a problem
what is he doing here come on
yeah he's probably playing this this
stuff every game
so he can um
play in bullet mode okay so
how do we do that line up for queen d3
so let's say queen d3 that's
f5 hmm
and let's do this
i want to get complete control of the
light squares if possible
i mean this is a completely ridiculous
setup
so
i just want to get bishop f5 maybe that
would be nice
and of course queen d3 is a much more
problematic threat so queen d3 or
i can also put it in here knight e6 take
takes also awful
but i have to be faster
just the two minutes it doesn't allow
for
um deep consideration
so i check
and now knight f5
yeah let's do that
now this is a nice compensation but
it doesn't look like i'm i'm winning
immediately that uh
and bishop yes that's extremely good but
yeah that's the thing do i take or not
it would actually open up the position
but
i don't think i want to do that at the
moment
take a bit of time here now this one the
question is if i can take on c5
now and crash through
it's definitely close to close call
that works or not
but this is also looking dangerous
and now i can take on c5 in both ways
and both look dangerous
maybe this one i don't know
i just have the one minute jam that's
not
not going to be so easy to
uh to win
it's close it's very close to working
and the capture but
this is this is what i want to play but
i'm not sure
hd1 queen f5 that it can be tricky i
mean
it's it's probably really nice but
his pieces are completely dead but
you still have to finish this in the
time
f5 i did not quite understand
[Music]
i could have taken already
ah stupid don't want to trade queens of
course
shooting for the knight coming to f5
i don't know if that even helps yeah i
mean he always has c3
okay let's not do it
i have to be somewhat faster here that
the 20 seconds are really
really it looks uh tough
what is he doing here queen b7 maybe
knight c3 no i take
i need i not
queen c3 rook b5 wins
what did i miss maybe nothing
just wants to irritate me i don't know
rook wants to go to c3
yeah e4 is a good move
trying to play for this pin
oops
no ah shoot
oops
i won this wow
okay i'm not going to get the first
place but maybe the second place
the guy here just wins all the games
even if i beat him
hey okay if your first place and you get
a 1600 then you're probably going to win
this thing
okay hey i'm not playing really all that
i'm just a bit slow and not really
killing off the completely winning
positions quickly
and i get all those
lame openings
that you never win quickly against you
know i mean this is not good for white
at all but
it's just going to take ages to to win
if you do win i'm sorry i mean it's not
like white is lost or anything but
it's kind of not the kind of thing that
you
just refute and uh and we and
have your points just um it's just
not very ambitious let's say but it's
not terrible
i can still cover f2 queen e2 or
something
yeah that was probably not so good
so anyway this is not really a good move
actually
um
man maybe i can do something with the
check on it too
bishop b2 i can always check and play
group c2 so that's not a thing
so let's attack the pawn
on a2 oh
that was nice okay come on let's trade
rooks
i was quick but
he's even on pause wow okay
yeah 13 points impossible in 11 minutes
i need
some kind of super crazy trick win which
is not my kind of play
i don't even know those openings
sometimes you see those funny videos i
really think they're cool like what
sometimes eric rosen recently showed
something like where you can win quickly
with black in the england gambit or
something
and i just don't know those things
this is just maybe uh what you need to
do here and i don't even get a game
which is completely weird just give me
again give me a game
please oh yeah this guy is playing the
the elephant gambit it's complete
rubbish but
if you can win you do quickly
i don't even get a game yet it's not
good video material
what's the thing here so maybe i can
get something quick going here
let's see if we can get a quick win
bishop takes h7
yes that's that's the way to do it
okay i was a bit lucky that's a trick i
know
97 do it shoot
that would have been fun you can still
do it no
knight takes you four take it
i think eric does those kind of things
oh my queen
no i didn't blunder the queen
yeah but maybe this kind of play i mean
that is not what i usually do
this is um like in your face attacking
play oops
is the way to um do it now in this
tournament situation
now this is an annoying pin note okay
i'm not going to move the bishop of
course
you can never take this
just not happening
how do we actually pose a thread rook
h3g3 maybe
yeah that's probably the way to do it
if he takes it the h file is going to be
completely devastating
so
i can still yeah it's close yeah
it's close but you can maybe take it
yeah but okay if anything i have to win
quickly i mean it's probably hopeless
anyway
with the time left to to catch the first
place
guy
but you never know threatening checkmate
is that a threat
check there is no threat yet so i can
take here
knight f4 e7 is a nice little trick
e7 is a threat anyway if he takes with
any piece i know
almost almost made knight takes rook h89
g8 is still
a way to defend but knight f4 would be a
relatively normal move that blunders the
house
yes
wow okay three points
three points now i need some england
style gambit to get me a quick win
somehow
first of all i need a game and i would
also of course just
like to beat this person but it doesn't
look like this is possible he's still in
a game
come on hey if he wins that
it's not so easy yeah depends on the
black player
what is that actually why does white is
a bit better
okay
let's hope for yeah
nah how can we do something crazy here
that's probably a complete non-starter
anyway
this one
if he castles i can go g5 that would be
a way to
maybe get something crazy on the board
i have to win really quickly
i mean to get it in on the scoreboard at
first yeah
what the f what the heck g4
i mean you know well i cannot really
criticize him for it
i would have done the same but um
it's a tournament situation in for me
but
i'm not really thinking it's objectively
good
to push it so early after castles you
can always play
the g pawn but um wow
that looks very dangerous
rook b6 i'm not actually threatening
this
he has queen a8
i mean whatever i need some luck
but that that's fine yeah i can simply
take this pawn why not
what is the deal here okay let's just
castle
knight xg4 is definitely i mean this
position looks completely winning
honestly
so let's keep the bishop there
and i i can take on g4 that's really
very close
let's take if he takes i'm it's over
right
there is no queen g3 i can just take the
queen
and against the king move i've got rook
f3
so that's that's totally over just the
question if he resigns or not
this is the thing it's like made almost
if he resigns i got some some chances
rook g6 coming
just need the additional piece to to
mate
white has no move anyway that that he
can play
at least i don't see anything good
queen h5 mate
it's almost pre-move territory yeah
that's nice
so i'm leading this thing and he lost
this guy lost
wow am i winning this tournament he
would need to win this game
here really quickly
if black in this game okay so i can
try something crazy trying to
try to win in some gambit style
oh god oh okay
all right it's a very nice oops come on
very nice position should be three would
be nice if he would
give me that
yeah it's probably not resigning
but um i might have better chances to
win this um
than my direct
that the other guy
and direct uh competition for the
tournament win checkmate would be good
like but probably i cannot
find a mate here
like this maybe i can
find a mate yes mate
that's enough that must be enough
yes i'm seven points ahead that's crazy
that's crazy and i hope your ears are
still
doing fine after my scream that was
crazy
to win this tournament but it was only
possible with those really quick wins
and of course that's luckier that you
run into a mate here
so let's let's have a look here what
kucho is doing he's in this game here
against indos
indo indo indoi wang
yeah i mean even if he wins it that is
the best that's that's that's possible
and he's not winning yeah it's uh equal
material
position at least yeah so it will be it
will be enough even if he gets a lucky
lucky win
yeah that's it i won this thing that's
that's weird
at the end yeah and um let me just have
a quick look at the tournament so that i
that that to see what happened so i had
this
this draw and then i lost this game yeah
against
unvero yeah i just want to i mean i
cannot really do analysis
and i don't want to it just meant as a
fun little video but
i just want to quickly check this
because i really
got into trouble
i think probably here
somewhere here
that that should be in equal position if
we switch on the engine
that should be in equal position and
it's uh confirmed by the comp i just
probably have to be a little bit more
circumspect
i think that probably queen b5 is bad
right
yeah that's more or less losing yeah
well
with berserking and you have to make
those quick decisions
yeah i don't know it's of course
something that i could
see but um when you play quickly
and he doesn't he didn't do anything
wrong i mean like if you
this is like well he didn't do anything
wrong
and i mean it was not so difficult yeah
the the movie were fairly
fairly uh natural right what he had to
do
so i probably um have to play queen c7
here
one thing that is probably a point
um maybe i shouldn't play d4
just for practical purposes in that
berserking situation
it's maybe better to just keep more
pieces on the board and play for made
yeah something like let's say develop
rook c8 queen d6 bishop b8 play play for
an attack i hope that the attack is just
hitting home
d4 is of course it's perfectly okay
objectively but
it's not so great for a berserking
situation maybe
here i'm fine but it's it's just boring
and you're not ever winning quickly or
so which which would be
of course helpful so to the the time
it's not a big factor
yeah i hope you enjoyed the video and
make sure if you are interested in one
of the courses yeah
they are on sale currently those three
and uh
yeah more to come um and of course the
lifetime repertoire is just as a
two-parter
and if you made it so far
in this video there's a peek inside 20
minutes of me
telling you some details and
there's a second part of course coming
in december so make sure to check it out
and thanks for watching bye bye